anticipation built throughout the day
outside dublin castle as one
constituency after another was declared
in favor of marriage equality a historic
event for the thousands who gathered to
celebrate never felt happier as I house
this day because we did it I'm so pre
did it I'm so probably to this country
I'm if vote for equality is the right
thing so I'm and thoroughly delighted in
the static today then the official
result was announced inside backers were
ecstatic a resounding majority in favor
of gay marriage in favor of the proposal
1 million two hundred 1607 support was
overwhelming and relatively liberal
Dublin but even conservative districts
in the majority Catholic country
generally voted yes for marriage
equality send this message to the world
and to LGBT young people in arden to the
cross the world the Ireland's is the
first country in the world to introduce
marriage equality by popular vote it's a
massive statement and we haven't just
done it by small numbers it's an
overwhelming vote more than sixty-five
percent of eligible voters turned out a
surprisingly high number many travel
back to Ireland to cast their ballots
since voting by mail is not allowed just
that there's been a ground sweat of
enthusiasm for this referendum
particular amongst new voters
and amongst young people something that
you don't usually see in Irish
referendums where there's usually quite
a low turnout the enthusiasm with the
campaign has been very very high and
that seems to be translating in the
polls which is great Ireland has changed
the influence of the Catholic Church has
waned many voters paid no attention to
sermons against same-sex marriage and
that in a country where homosexuality
was outlawed until 22 years ago